كما تعلم أننا طرحنا أسئلتك
حول هذه الأدوية الجديدة لإنقاص الوزن
وأرسلت المئات منها، وهي
أكثر الأشياء شيوعًا حول الآثار الجانبية
الآن، وأنا أجيب على هذا، أريدك أن تضع
في اعتبارك أن إحدى الطرق التي تعمل بها هذه الأدوية
هي أدوية glp1  هو إبطاء
سرعة تحرك الطعام عبر
أمعائك، لذا ربما لا يكون مفاجئًا إذن أن
الآثار الجانبية الأكثر شيوعًا هي أشياء مثل
الغثيان والقيء والإمساك،
وهذا جزء من السبب الذي يجعل الأطباء
يزيدون الجرعة ببطء مما يسمح
لجسمك بالتعود عليها.  الآن، يمكن أن يكون حوالي 1%
من الحالات أكثر خطورة، مثل انسداد
القوس الفعلي، وشلل المعدة، والتهاب
البنكرياس، وقد تتذكر أن هناك
أيضًا بعض التقارير المثيرة للقلق التي تفيد
بأن الأشخاص كانوا يفكرون في الانتحار
أثناء تناول هذه الأدوية، لكن
دراسة حديثة لم تظهر زيادة خطر الإصابة بالانتحار.
هذا هو الوقت المبكر، لا تزال هذه
الأدوية ليست للجميع ولكن
يبدو أنها آمنة في الغالب مع
هذه التحذيرات، إلى متى يمكنك البقاء على
هذه الأدوية بشكل جيد،
الأدوية الطبية تحاكي هذا الهرمون الذي يتم
إطلاقه بعد تناول وجبة ما يجعلك
تعتقد ذلك  لقد أكلت للتو حتى
لو لم تأكل، يطلق عليه
هرمون ما بعد المغذيات، وقد تمت
الموافقة عليه بالفعل في عام 2005 لمساعدة مرضى
السكري على التحكم في نسبة السكر في الدم، وقد
وجد لاحقًا أنه
يؤدي أيضًا إلى فقدان الوزن، هناك
شيئان مهمان تم تعلمهما  بادئ ذي بدء،
بدت بيانات السلامة طويلة المدى لهذه الأدوية واعدة جدًا وكان
التوقع هو أن هؤلاء المرضى
سيستمرون في تناول هذه الأدوية لفترة طويلة.
الآن سأقول أن هناك
أدوية أحدث وجرعات أحدث وهناك عدد
أكبر من الأشخاص الذين يستخدمون هذه الأدوية أكثر من أي وقت مضى  نحن الآن
نتناول هذه الأدوية، لذا
سنتعلم الكثير ولكن فيما يتعلق بفقدان الوزن
في هذه المرحلة، لا توجد إجابات حاسمة وسريعة
حول المدة التي يمكن أو
يجب أن يستمر الشخص في تناولها فيها، فمن الممكن أن
يستمر الأشخاص في تناول هذه الأدوية لمدة
وقت طويل تمامًا كما هو الحال بالنسبة
لمرض السكري، ماذا يحدث عندما تتوقف عن
تناول أدوية إنقاص الوزن هذه؟ هذا
هو السؤال المليون أو ربما المليار دولار
هنا. لقد أظهرت العديد من الدراسات
أن الناس يستعيدون الوزن
بعد التوقف عن تناول الأدوية، وأنا أدرك
أنه من المحبط سماع ذلك ولكن
يختلف الأمر بعض الشيء باختلاف
الأشخاص، أظهرت هذه الدراسة الحديثة على سبيل المثال
أنه بعد عام واحد من إيقاف OIC،
يحافظ حوالي 20% من الأشخاص على بعض
فقدان الوزن، ويستمر 36% من الأشخاص
في فقدان الوزن الآن، وليس من الواضح ما الذي
كان يفعله هؤلاء الأشخاص
بشكل مختلف ولكن من الواضح أن
الأدوية تتطلب أيضًا
تغييرات مخصصة جدًا في نمط الحياة، فهي ليست
حبة سحرية أو حقنة سحرية في هذه الحالة،
سيستغرق الأمر بضع سنوات أخرى
للدراسة لمعرفة من هو الذي
سيستفيد أكثر  وإذا كنت ترغب في
الاستمرار في معرفة المزيد حول هذا الأمر، فاتبع
البودكاست الخاص بي Chasing Life، فنحن نستكشف
الوزن وفقدان الوزن طوال الموسم